i contemplated i had to die to my father
who died on myself and i realized that i
would rather die to him and so my fears
were relatively justified he was not in
support of the things that i wanted to
do i ended up quitting that job sold
everything i had packed my car went to
california because that's where i
thought the land of fitness opportunity
was because that was the only thing i
really enjoyed mentored under a guy for
a few months to try and at least learn
the ropes started my first facility
slept on the floor for the first nine
months which was a very terrible
experience for me two years and that was
really at the time it was at the a
splitting point where i had done two
years and the kind of career path
traditionally is like two to four years
of management consulting and then you go
back to an ivy league for your gmat and
then from there you go into do
investment banking you can do private
equity you can do you know some of the
bigger white collar jobs but i just
didn't i didn't want more of what i had
i thought that i would have a better
shot taking 200 000 in two years which
is what the you know economic equivalent
of what the degree was and starting
something on my own i figured i would
learn more in the first two years and
with that money and maybe even have a
business by the end of that period of
time that made an equivalent amount of
money compared to what i would have had
as a job offer